get ready to take on the circle the
circle has no chill this is gonna get
ugly I love it no not that one okay much
better get ready to be blasted with
angel fire because we have an all new
season of altered carbon season to cease
anthony mackie the dude from black mir
who kissed the other dude but it's
totally not gay because it's in a video
game take on the role of Takeshi Kovach
and a new and improved sleep in this
video we're gonna take a deep dive in in
the ending and what it could mean for
season 3 the final episode entitled
broken Angels sees our heroes hunted by
the Protectorate these Protectorate
forces are under the orders of Danica
Harlan who declared martial law putting
them under her control she's also the
one who orchestrated the callous
uprising in order to drive up the price
of alloy the material used to create
stacks leading the attack on Kovach and
his crew is a nother Takeshi coetc one
who's been double sleeved a term used
when more than one sleeve is inhabited
by this same consciousness or digital
human Freight dhf for short for the
purposes of this video and to keep
things easy to understand I'll be
referring to anthony mackie sleeve as
Kovich and the copy as Takeshi Takeshi
sleeve was brought back from a copy made
over three hundred years ago before the
events of season 1 and even before
Takeshi met and fell in love with kel
Chris Falconer and when it looks like
there's no way out for Kovach and the
crew Takeshi switches side taking out
all of his own men meanwhile Poe tells
the gang that the construct they used to
contain the elder appears to be empty
throughout the season kel 'christ has
been fighting something with Hinna
that's taken over her body they find out
that two consciousnesses are inhabiting
her stack so they devised a plan to
separate one conscious from the other
and trap the infected one within a
construct little do they know that the
consciousness inhabiting kel 'christ
isn't human at all but that of an elder
an ancient alien race that existed
millennia before the arrival of Connor
and Harland and humanity on Harlin's
world in fact Conrad impatient to
colonize this new planet destroyed any
of the remaining elders so that humanity
could exploit and colonize one elder
however survived clinging to the song
spire trees roots it was only when kel
Chris Falconer was
placed in a glass coffin next to the
song spire tree that the elder was able
to leach into quel Chris psyche allowing
her to take revenge on the founders who
had murdered her people Poe and Miss
Diggs construct trap was a failure
nothing seems to be contained within it
that's because the elder was able to
inhabit and control the sleeve of
colonel Ivan Carrara meaning that if he
isn't stopped he could incinerate the
entire planet by being able to control
angel fire angel fires the weapon Danica
has been searching for the entire season
a weapon which could give her leverage
against the Protectorate meanwhile the
elder reclaims some ancient artifacts
which will later be used to control the
angel file while trep finds her father
dead and his stack missing he was killed
a few episodes by takeshi kel crisco h
and takeshi visit Danica in a last-ditch
attempt to save the planet they believe
that if they give the elder Conrad
Harlan stack the final remaining founder
who killed off the elders people that it
will stop its attack in exchange for
saving the planet kal once saved
transport offworld
but they're interrupted by Poe who
informs them that the orbitals are
moving orbitals are also known as angels
hence the name of the episode broken
Angels when they are in alignment
they'll send a destructive blast of
angel fire below miss digs data
extracting program has arrived in the
form of Miss Elizabeth who Poe wants to
hold him together long enough to
complete his task after that his memory
will be wiped so he can start anew since
his character has slowly been
deteriorating over the course of the
season Kovach who has been quite hard on
Poe over the course of the season
reassures Poe he finally figured out
what it means to be alive we're all
Broken Bow
it's nothing more human than that Kovich
also has his final heart-to-heart with
Kell Crest who reveals her true plan
she's gonna kill the elder force it back
into her and when their minds are
intertwined control the orbital to kill
them both
she feels partly responsible for this
whole mess after all she was the creator
of Stax and part of the reason Harlan's
world needed to be colonized were the
minds that contained the material to
make those stacks in her mind I have to
make it right
Kovach takes this as her not choosing
him I wish you loved me enough to live
which is ironic since he ends up
sacrificing himself so that she could
live Cal Kovach and Danica arrived to
exchange Conrad stack which the elder
seems pleased with when Danica uses the
opportunity to shoot him earlier in the
episode Danica is told that the elder
stoled react LeMay ssin drugs which this
vial likely is giving him that extra
boost to complete his mission Danica is
killed by him in the angel fire attack
continues to rev up with Kovach in the
elder fighting Kovach wants Yaeger the
man inside Carreras leave to fight
against the elder if Kell can break free
from its control maybe he can too and he
does for a moment but is too blinded by
resentment to come to his senses for
Yaeger Kovach and him shared a special
bond you're supposed to be but Kovich
ended up choosing his sister over him
Kovach eventually gets the upper hand
but can't shoot Yaeger because his
sleeve does not allow him but he finds a
workout by forcing Yaeger to pull the
trigger himself it's all too late
however as the angel fire lands directly
on Kovach turning him into ash and
obliterating his stack in the process
but the show really doesn't explain is
how the blast didn't end up destroying
the entire building kind of like what
happened earlier in the season where the
forest was completely destroyed perhaps
Kovach's sleeve acted as a conduit and
took most of the fire power before
disintegrating
several months later takeshi stands
before a new council on Harlan's world
testifying that kel chris falconer was
among those who died in the angel fire
even though no evidence of her sleeve
was found trip is finally reunited with
her wife and son looking like she's
finally quit the bounty hunting business
and is ready to settle down for good and
kel 'christ is alive and well heading
off world
to start a new uprising somewhere else
she's visited by a vision of Kovach who
says but we soon find out that Kovich
isn't gone for good moments before he
was obliterated po was able to copy his
dhf and upload it before his memory was
wiped even wrote it down on a post-it
note to remind himself after three
months of decompression PO appears in
front of mistake who was aptly named
herself Annabel after one of Edgar Allen
Poe's poems there's a glimmer of hope
that he may have retained some of his
memories memories which Anibal says may
start to come back to him over time she
finds his posted note which contains a
decryption key a key that opens raw data
to a human dhf that of Takeshi Kovach so
what does this mean for season 3 well
we'll likely have an entirely new actor
played Takeshi Kovach in a new sleeve
and don't count out Kell crest and the
Takeshi copy making another appearance I
wouldn't be surprised if season 3 takes
place on an entirely new planet since
the Harlin's world story seems to have
reached a proper conclusion remember
also that thirty years passed since the
events of season one and two so season
three could see us fast-forward multiple
decades or centuries depending on the
story the writers want to tell either
way I'll be interested what new sleeve
awaits Kovach let's go thanks for
watching everyone please be sure to LIKE
and subscribe and let me know what you
thought about the season in the comments
below you can also follow me on twitter
at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
[Music]